do you think people find a nobility and
being poor and they view that Oh having
money is part of the evil corporate
giant that is holding so many people
down man I'm so glad you asked that
question it reminds me of about one of
these hops tables it's about Fox and the
grapes and Fox is walking along a path
and he sees the grave looks up I'm
paraphrasing obviously in he keeps
trying to get the grapes he can't get
the grapes and when he finally gives up
his his that this grapes were bad anyway
these people are the Fox and snake open
America's not holding you down your life
doesn't suck because Wall Street that's
your life sucks probably
because you've made the wrong choices
you have not adapted or you haven't
figured it out yet it's not necessarily
a bad thing but don't be mad at some
stranger e to start just write off an
entire cross section of people you're
doing the very same thing that you think
is wrong you're stereotyping the most
guys work on Wall Streeter just kind of
make money they're just they're just
normal guys and get why I have so you've
got kids there's some bad apples there's
also bad doctors there's a lot of bad
actors they use drugs and it wastes the
beautiful opportunity that they had to
live fantastic lives and look about
these Hollywood people how many of them
how many of them open their house to
out-of-home say people in Compton some
of them they throw money at a problem
and I think that makes him a good person
there are some people I mean look I
couldn't disagree with Sean Penn more
about a lot of things but I would say
this about Sean Penn that guy went to
Haiti and he hangs out there he puts his
money where his mouth is he actually
doesn't work and I can't stand this
political view and I think he's but I
think his personality is he's a
cantankerous and temperamental dude I
like the guy but I I will say this he
walks the walk so you know these people
that sit around thinking that that
they're not accomplished
a dream because of this evil corporate
cabal why don't you bring those guys an
idea that makes money you'll get their
attention you bring them an audience of
10 million don't pay attention even
always for one going they'll pay
attention to you because it's it's
business it's not about blacks not about
white it's about green and that's just
reality and that will that will never
change no matter how what are you going
to do like let's apply the disco to
quote occupy 99% mentality to Hollywood
so let's say for example we're going to
say now that it's not fair that Michael
Moore has done X amount of good
documentaries so no matter how good is
document X documentary is and I can't
stand these documentaries but we're just
going to not release this film because
it's not fair we're gonna kick some
unknown guy with a lousy documentary
that nobody really wants to see and
we're going to give him the same amount
of press we're going to put it out there
we've spent millions of dollars
promoting that which we know is not a
demand and will likely fail because
that's the fair thing to do that would
be absurd but for some reason we've
developed this mentality where we now
disdain success we disdain companies
companies didn't start out as
multi-million dollar conglomerate they
didn't wake up one day and have a
hundred billion dollars they started off
with a person or a group of people to
had an idea the motivation of the drive
to succeed now does that mean that
corporate America doesn't write things
all the time no they do it's in their
own best interest just like actors do
just like actors who you know I don't
know if you're going on an audition and
you've got friends that that might be
going for the same role and you found
out about that audition do you want to
tell your friends some don't is that
fair you know demi coupé bad personal
you doing what's in your own best
interest you make decisions that benefit
you and it's just interesting to me that
the people that are the Fox looking up
with the grapes have all these judgments
about the graves instead of saying how
can I get up there how can I figure out
a way to get up there instead of
trashing those who discovered what they
haven't figured out I alt look I spent
years making lousy pay working graveyard
shift meanwhile everyone else was
partying or on a sunday night drinking
beer barbecues I was working if you
remember I mean back then I would work
Monday through Friday graveyard shift
and then on Saturday I'd work nine to
five Saturday 925 Sunday go home take a
quick nap shower go to a BBQ eat a
couple burgers and then take off and
then work graveyard shift in a Monday
and that was my life and I did that did
it with no medical benefits I found a
way I just kept trying to get close to
the target and now here we are all these
years later and now I'm married have a
nice car i just bought a place i can
afford nice things now I gotta see Obama
get up there and talk about how I'm
fortunate how I'm privileged and how
somehow I need to pay more I see every
month one half of my income yet withheld
half now a my own rayful oh I feel
blessed but if you're already holding
back half how could you make that case
for the straight face somehow i'm not
paying my fair share I work my ass off
and anyone who knows me knows the amount
of hours I work because instead of going
to vegas and playing around a couple
times a year like everyone else was i
was working i did the work and then
magically after a technique you know
working in radio i get an opportunity to
have my own radio show
and how did you get that I put in about
10 years and then you know as we sit
here my office wow it's amazing how'd
you get that but in about ten years you
know so I think that we need to change
the mentality in this country and stop
hating those who've accomplished in and
it's become the trend and it's dangerous
and it's not that it's kind of
productive oh we can all be equally
miserable no that's not what America is
it's about going out there and you have
the unlimited potential and you have the
the pursuit of happiness it starts up
appt about that you know life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness not the
guarantee of success
you